hey there and welcome to conan o'brien
needs a friend
so far this is my best intro ever it's
confident
it was good and to the point that was
good right i wasn't in my head good and
then you called attention to it and
ruined it well did i or in a weird weird
way
oh you ruined it it started off so good
and then you just ruined it you know i
have a bubble in my brain that causes me
to occasionally mispronounce a very easy
word like weird and i went weird i love
calling it out because then you get very
like uh defensive about it you're like
where does how they've always pronounced
it this is how it's pronounced you know
my favorite is when people say i've
heard it both ways when they're clearly
wrong i love that when someone says
anyway i'm here and of course i live in
north america and someone go like what
you mean north america and they'll be
like i've heard it actually both ways
that's you no no that's not me that is
you no no uh please i own my mistakes if
and when i ever make one
i will own it no we're still waiting
never never own them you only outsource
them to underlings
i outsource all my mistakes and blenders
to
to offshore companies um
it'd be really funny if i had these uh
you know like you know other people hide
money
or they they you know play these
international games where they keep
money and like i've got some money in
the bahamas or bermuda and they shut a
little around i would love that i just
make a ton of mistakes but i constantly
hide them in offshore accounts and banks
actual mistakes if there was a way to
hide mistakes errors
uh omissions and blunders and all of
mine were kept so people thought wow
conan
he doesn't make mistakes because then
somebody right grand jury justice
committee finds them and get access to
that right and they find all of your
mistakes they find hundreds of thousands
of incredible mistakes and errors and
faux pas and blunders yeah and they've
all been kept in these special accounts
that would be a show like severance
a really cool sci-fi show you know the
way there's it's very popular now to
have shows where you know people can
store their consciousness here or there
what about a show where i'm a character
who can store
all of his mistakes and embarrassing
faux pas yeah that's what this podcast
is is there enough
do you think that's what this is
oh and you have them all you've you've
collected them all you've edited them
out yeah and so i got you over a barrel
man not enough space oh okay all right
i'm saying you mess up a lot i don't and
you mispronounce things a lot i just
don't know if there would be space
there's no cloud no there's no cloud big
enough to hold your mistake
oh your faux pas what if that's what
brings down all the servers
we tried to store all my mistakes
and all the servers that netflix is
using and all these different google
amazon amazon all these massive servers
that are in the desert somewhere and
they were all comfortably handling all
human knowledge all purchases and all
entertainment that's ever been made for
anyone who wants it anytime and then we
started storing
the audio mistakes i've made on the
podcast and all of them melt down
and suddenly we become this society
that's just feral no one can
people are running around it's mad max
beyond thunderdome it's mad and the only
currency is that your mistakes are nfts
that can be traded in a thunderdome yeah
and so uh conan instead of saying
hurricane said harukon
because he spoke too quickly and it came
out huracan that's worth thirty five
thousand dollars
and people in the future are wandering
around in sort of a
post-apocalyptic society wearing shreds
and rags but they go in and someone has
a piece of ham and they buy
that piece of ham with conan's attempt
to say herbert hoover but he said
herbert hover i'm having a really hard
time following this well yeah i'm so
sorry
i don't had a dime for every time we had
this exact conversation
[Laughter]
i think we should come up with a really
good idea for a show i don't know if we
did that's wait i'm checking and we
didn't no i don't terrible show awful
show no i don't put it in the mistake
paul in a future world conan's mistakes
are nfts they're the only thing that can
purchase food so no one heard them
you remove them they were all put on a
server by gourley uh-huh the server
ended up crashing the system yeah yeah
yeah and then in the future society
collapsed yeah society collapsed but
then my mistakes become currency okay
you know conan's mispronunciation of
president herbert hoover yeah i'm glad
we're clarifying this yeah yeah yeah
yeah this all makes sense now i'm
doubling down on this terrible idea
yeah i think you should all right i
think this whole thing is going to be a
mistake
yeah this is the biggest one and the
most valuable nft you're going to have
yeah all right well i'm glad i said my
piece